donald trump spricht wie ein kind
hochentwickelt pflaster gegen diabetes
und wird bald ein neues
elementarteilchen entdeckt das sind drei
der fünf themen jetzt in den krieg zum
top five news donald trump spricht wie
ein gen quantität ist eben nicht gleich
qualität forscher der carnegie mellon
university haben sich reden von us
politikern angeschaut und ihre grammatik
und ihren wortschatz ausgewertet und
besonders schlecht abgeschnitten hat
dabei donald trump den forschern zur
folge hätte er sprach fähigkeiten eines
fünf- bis siebtklässler
er liegt damit übrigens auf dem niveau
von george tabori opus hochentwickeltes
pflaster diabetes eine
stoffwechselerkrankung an der weltweit
415 millionen menschen leiden könnte für
die betroffenen bald angenehmer zu
behandeln seien
ein mensch der unter diabetes leidet hat
vereinfacht gesagt entweder einen
insulinmangel das wäre dann diabetes
mellitus typ 1 oder 1 nicht effizient
wirksames körpereigenes insulin dann
spricht man von diabetes mellitus typ 2
fehlt insulin erleiden die betroffenen
eine überzuckerung eine hyperglykämie
der zucker ist im blut und ist nicht
mehr als energielieferant in den zellen
auch fettsäuren werden ins blut
abgegeben
die folgen können erblindung oder ein
schlaganfall seien dagegen müssen
patienten sich eine insulinspritze
setzen regelmäßig um den aufwand um das
risiko einer zu spät gesetzte spritze zu
verringern haben forscher der ohio
university ein neuartiges pflaster
entwickelt das blutzucker ph-werte
feuchtigkeit und temperatur misst und
bei bedarf über mikro nadeln ein
diabetesmedikament ins blut in den vier
zitat die behandlung durch die haut ist
sehr viel effektiver als über den
verdauungstrakt weil das mittel so
direkt in das blut gelangt und den
stoffwechsel berichten die forscher jede
einzelne nadel wurde mit einer drehzahl
neue geschichte die beschichtung
verhindert ein frühzeitiges freisetzen
des medikaments registrieren die
sensoren eine überzuckerung werden die
nadeln erhitzt 3d zahn säure verdampft
bei rund 41 grad der wirkstoff wird ins
blut befördert zitat auch wenn eine
praxistaugliche lösung bisher noch nicht
griffbereit ist liest ihm ist im ziel
auf jeden fall ein gutes stück näher
gerückt pharmakologe richard greil von
der university of bath
eine 11 tausend lichtjahre lange und
2300 lichtjahre breite interstellare
wolke aus wasserstoffgas steuert
ungebremst auf unsere milchstraße zu
die miss wolke ist noch rund 8000
lichtjahre von uns entfernt warum noch
sie hält mit 240 kilometern pro sekunde
kurs auf uns und in 30 millionen jahren
wird sie mit unserer galaxie kollidieren
geschieht das werden nasa
wissenschaftlern zufolge millionen neue
sterne entstehen
unsere heimatgalaxie steht also ein
enormer sternen zuwachs bevor
interessantes auch eine kürzlich
gemachte entdeckung über diese mehrere
millionen sonnenmassen schwere wolke mit
hilfe des weltraumteleskops hubble
konnte jetzt die herkunft der wolke
bestimmt werden sie soll vor rund 70
millionen jahren ein bestandteil der
milchstraße gewesen sein der dann hinaus
geschleudert wurde
in der folge wurde schwefel nachgewiesen
dass schwere element weist auf die
milchstraße als herkunft hin wäre sie
außerhalb entstanden würde sie nur aus
wasserstoff und helium bestehen so
gleicht ihre zusammensetzung den
außenbereichen unserer galaxie die
eigene stimme zum ersten mal gehört wie
bewegend wissenschaft sein kann zeigen
wir euch gleich in einem video forscher
im us bundesstaat mississippi konnten
einer frau die von geburt an gehörlos
war ermöglichen zum ersten mal zu hören
die junge frau hört also das erste mal
ihre eigene stimme die stimme ihrer
mutter und ihres freundes
ist das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik veraltet auf den spuren
eines neuen elementarteilchen zitat
nachdem wir sozusagen die pflicht mit
der entdeckung des higgs teilchens
absolviert haben geht es jetzt um die
kür das heißt wir suchen am lhc sehr
intensiv nach neuen effekten die über
das standardmodell hinaus weisen so
peter mättig gegenüber welt der physik
de forscher am cern in genf vermuten die
existenz eines revolutionären
elementarteilchen das war eine masse von
750 gb elektronen volt haben und wäre
somit mit dem standardmodell der
teilchenphysik nicht zu erklären
erklärte peter mättig dem team vom
wetter physik de zitat mit dem higgs
haben wir das letzte vorhergesagte
teilchen gefunden
im standardmodell kommt ein teilchen mit
einer masse von 57 gigaelektronenvolt
das unter anderem in zwei photonen
zerfällt nicht vor
zwar wurden auch bei vorherigen
messungen schon vereinzelt ereignisse
bei dieser energie gesehen aber die
wurden nicht ernst genommen weil sie
nicht deutlich genug waren jetzt beim
neuen lauf haben die physiker die
kollisionsenergie im beschleuniger von
acht auf 13 tera elektronenvolt
hochgeschraubt und damit lassen sich
teilchen mit großen massen besser finden
das signal ist jetzt deutlicher wenn es
sich wirklich als real herausstellt dann
existiert ein neues teilchen das mit dem
bekannten physikalischen theorien nicht
erklärt werden kann
das heißt wenn es dieses teilchen gibt
weist uns das in einer richtung einer
neuen physik
berichtet peter mättig weiter im april
diesen jahres wollen die forscher am
cern einen neuen versuch starten um die
existenz dieses teilchens zu beweisen
peter mättig hält es für möglich dass am
ende des jahres bekannt sein könnte ob
es wirklich ein solch massereiches
elementarteilchen gibt oder nicht
ich freue mich über einen daumen nach
oben wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
und natürlich nicht vergessen ein
kostenloses abo wenn er mehr videos von
uns sehen wollt und was meint ihr wie
viel wissen wir eigentlich wenn jetzt
schon wieder ein neues elementarteilchen
entdeckt wird was alles auf den kopf
stellen wird wann sind wir endlich mal
so weit dass wir wirklich annähernd
alles in anführungszeichen wissen
diskutiert es in den kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran und
vergesst nicht das nächste video zu
gucken